[Music]
php a dynamic interpreted scripting
language for building interactive
websites on the server despite the
haters pronouncing it dead it remains
one of the most popular languages for
back-end web development it powers
content management systems like
wordpress top-tier websites like
wikipedia and countless others via
frameworks like laravel and symphony
hell man even facebook uses it although
they built a custom compiler to convert
it to machine code on their servers it
was created in 1994 by rasmus lyrdorf to
manage his personal home page clever
acronym but it sounds lame for a
language that powers multi-billion
dollar enterprises so today we practice
cognitive dissonance to tell ourselves
php stands for hypertext preprocessor it
has a special place in history because
it predates javascript and was one of
the first languages to be embedded
directly in html allowing websites to be
built dynamically on a server it's open
source and was one of the technologies
that revolutionized the web by making
application development accessible to
the average person its interpreter is
implemented in c and has a syntax
inspired by perl to get started create a
php file and add some basic html to it
within this file you can go into php
mode by opening a question mark php tag
the code within these tags will be
rendered on the server use echo to
output a value and the location of the
tag to declare a variable give it a name
that starts with a dollar sign followed
by a value it's a weekly typed language
so no type annotations are necessary it
also comes with a large number of
predefined variables geared towards web
development like git post and cookie
which contain information about the
incoming http request now when this code
is rendered on your server it will
output an html string with the php tags
being replaced by whatever you echoed
the language also supports multiple
programming paradigms you have first
class functions which can be assigned to
variables or used anonymously as
arguments and it has tons and tons of
built-in functions to do pretty much
anything a web developer could ever
imagine doing it also has a complete
object model where you can define
classes with inheritance to implement
object-oriented patterns we're currently
on php version 8 which has all the
features you would expect from a modern
pragmatic language every web developer
should be familiar with it because
statistically there's a 78.5 chance that
your client's website is running the
personal homepage language this has been
php in 100 seconds hit the like button
if you want to see more short videos
like this thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one